donald trump was memed into the
presidency have you guys seen that uh
that doc that that internet
history about meme magic and all the
weird stuff that happened
you know about it have i seen it
did you make it
do not speak to me
about the deep
i was there when it was written
when it was written yo the donald trump
keck conspiracy stuff
it's crazy they summoned a an egyptian
chaos god
right
right which no because people were and
you know because there was a certain
avatar meme that was very popular in
2015 and 2016 of a frog alt-right you
know you know of course right which
which again it had nothing to do with
with
that sort of thing it was just sort of
like
it was it was the idea that and frogs
have generally been associated with with
like chaos right for you know throughout
history
and
they're they're just they're okay
they're a chaotic creature ever try to
catch one and so people are looking this
up and apparently the egyptian god of
chaos was actually a frog named kak
named keck here's and this is how crazy
it is right in world of warcraft when
you were playing the opposing faction if
you were playing the alliance you saw
the horde if they typed lol the
translator would turn it into kek so a
meme emerged among young people where
they would say kek instead of lol for
laugh out loud right kak is the egyptian
god of chaos a frog pepe then there was
that uh that album
what was that album with the
chatelaine with and it was a frog it was
italian right all these weird things
started coming together
and then there's just a whole bunch of
like 4chan posts where it was like
someone said something like if i get
trips so when you post you get a code a
string of a string of numbers and
they're like if i if you get three in a
row at the end something happens and it
was like all sevens or whatever it was
like donald trump becomes president and
the whole post was all sevens it legit
it's like
probably one of the funnest and funniest
i wouldn't call it a conspiracy theory
but like trippy internet video to watch
that you want to believe is true all
this crazy ian's freaking out you're
making me think of pattern recognition
patterns because i don't think that
we're as free and and wild and chaotic
as we seem as humans or as reality
exists like it it does seem like we're
cycling towards a pat like involved in
some sort of
megastructure that we don't necessarily
or that i don't
understand right now
well there's even the um the egyptian
hieroglyphic for keck if i remember
correctly
it it looks like a guy at a computer no
that was fake that was fake that was
fake yeah yeah oh really yes oh no no
they were real hieroglyphics yeah but
they didn't say kek and then so people
put it together because it was funny oh
no way that sucks yeah that's the
reality of a lot of the stuff you think
is my favorite one
i don't think the because it was like a
guy at a computer and then there was
like a symbol in between
and then there was
and then there was and there was a guy
right and they said that the symbol in
between was meme magic happening well
this is why they had to uh get rid of
these social media platforms because um
and i'm saying this as a joke because
people were using them to effectively
pray and mass to cack egyptian god of
chaos and it was working so the powers
that be the big tech silicon valley
people banned them to stop the praying
to kek that's true i'm kidding
so is this why elon hasn't tweeted in
over a week this is the actual actual
keck thing it's it's it is there is a
person sitting there that's pretty close
but it's pretty close to what the other
one was right but the other one had it
would look like it's
more like a
i i don't i don't think anyone saw it
coming i mean i i might even roll the
dice here and say that no one on earth
saw this connection before it happened
so what the lol would spell keck which
was a frog that they used to laugh with
pepe
so it all it sort of just came together
this way and it's very crazy like in
world of warcraft kakamet laugh out loud
so people started saying kak instead of
life out loud the pepe meme emerges then
people start discovering that kak is a
real thing there was kakistan you know
the kind of oh i know well i was a mines
moderator at the time
so you're like well here's the home of
the kekistan essentially for about a
year the oppressed kakistani people tim
do you think that we are in like a
vibrational
struck like a in like a a simulation is
a vague way of saying but do you think
we're in like a pattern in a pattern the
universe is of course a pattern
everything functions
like math proves the universe is is a
pattern it's a massive one we can't
comprehend the entirety of at least as
far as we can tell but uh if there was
no pattern we'd be chaos there'd be no
order there'd be no structure there'd be
no human body there'd be no stars so of
course there's pattern
and if people if you pay attention you
start to see the pattern but a lot of
people aren't paying attention i noticed
with internet it's like have you have
you talked whenever we talk to people
who do dmt
they're like the machine elves tell you
that i think michael mouse is saying
this that uh reality is like a song yeah
it goes in loops with like here's the
here's the chorus and then here's the
body and then it loops and it's just
like
music being played uh cernovich has been
doing a lot of uh interviews lately
about ayahuasca which is which is simply
sort of like the plant-based version of
dnt
and he was on with with alex clark on
spillover talking about this and he did
an interview with charlie kirk about it
and one thing that he said and
that i thought was interesting was
that he said it people say are you
hallucinating he said no it felt like
the hallucination was falling away
like like that place felt
more real like this is where it all
started i've heard that and
and you realize that the world that we
we perceive as the real world is like
that's the one that is the hallucination
you want you want to hear something
funny to everybody listening i'll tell
you exactly what's going to happen i
know what the afterlife is you guys
ready for this let's go every single
person watching the show
one day your time will come
and then as you pass
you will see a bright light in front of
you that you will rush through and then
all of a sudden you'll sit up from your
couch and you're ian and you're like
whoa
oh good
we ought to be good for you
ayahuasca is very interesting it's a
combination of a a vine and a root bark
the mimosa root bark and they boil them
together and they boil them again and
then um you drink it and it
your body starts producing dmt
endogenously meaning from the inside you
make your own dmt and then there's
normally your body can inhibit the dmt
so you don't always you're not always
tripping but it has an inhibitor for the
inhibitor well so you consume it what
happens is
the plant has dimethyltryptamine was it
dimethyltryptamine that's dmt dmt in it
but your body will destroy it and it
won't be absorbed when they mix it
they're adding an maoi inhibitor which
bonds to it and allows it to enter your
body and then
so it's in the plant and your body
starts producing it in excess maybe
that's what now i've only sipped on
ayahuasca and it was delicious it tasted
like grass like if you ever chew on
grass it's very bitter it was really
concentrated dark brown grass juice and
i sipped on it and immediately felt the
dmt uh clarity like when i go into chat
when i make an internet youtube videos
or internet videos and i start
channeling my thoughts and i don't even
remember what i said but that's why i
started recording them in the first
place because i was like i remember it
was cool what i said i just don't
remember what it was how long is the
house that's when you're drinking it uh
it was like for i took a sip and then it
was like within 30 seconds i felt that
rush of clarity and then after about a
minute it was started to dip dip out but
i just was taking a tiny sip wow just to
just to clarify i know the surface level
stuff about ayahuasca but just to pull
it up ayahuasca is notorious for its
psychedelic properties produced from the
combination of maois found in
benisteriopsis
copy vine and nn dimethyltryptamine from
psycho
psychotria viridis
or diplopterus
carburana basically
it is um
it's a so maoi inhibitor is a um what's
what's what's the word the i means
inhibitor exactly so what there's a word
for when you say atm machine yeah it's
like repetitive yeah there's a word for
that it's called the monoamine oxidase
inhibitor so mao inhibitors yes
yeah that that at the same time as dmt
allows your body to absorb it that's
what people do i i'm really fascinated
by this dmt is a fascinating subject and
especially with all the weird meme magic
and stuff i don't understand
how an adult human
can't look at the scientific research on
dmt
look at the the history of ayahuasca
and then look at the strange phenomenon
around things like meme magic and deja
vu and all of these strange things and
not just conclude there is something
magical to the universe beyond our
conference and the history to um
to put out there i mean this is this is
south american this is the am this is
the amazonians this is peru
uh this is something that that has gone
back i mean you're there and there are
there are stories that have come out of
the amazon talking about these types of
um
what we would consider hallucinations or
hallucinogens and you know people
essentially state that this was the
shamanistic drink right this is
something that goes back thousands of
years did you guys see the i think
there's a panther chewing on the vine
and then tripping his balls off it's a
video on youtube he's rolling around and
looking at the sky it's so awesome wow
yeah it's not just for humans
joe rogan was talking about a couple
years ago i was uh um you know whenever
i talk to people about religion and
stuff i always talk about how they're
just there there are things that seem to
be beyond probability
that it seems so incredibly rare that it
it's it
sure it could happen or that perhaps as
close as you get to a miracle
but the meme magic stuff you can explain
away a whole lot of how did you know
pepe come to be the similar what does it
mean what does it mean where did come
from well someone noticed there was an
egyptian deity which was a frog named
kak and they said hey it's really funny
that we use the frog meme and we say kak
so they make keck the god some of that
can be explained away but a lot of that
coincidence is just purely chaotic and
magical in some sense i don't mean magic
like a genie blinking and manifesting i
mean just like serendipitous like there
is an ebb and flow to the universe and
things that you'd think are
are rare are less rare than they really
are
then you listen to these stories about
the research on dmt how people trip on
dmt but then share an experience and
you're like there's something else out
there how was it was it they just shared
was it what they shared the experience
or was it that i think the study that i
read was that they had the same
experience um separately no no um
people like uh i'm not gonna name people
but people you've known from the show
like we've talked to have said they were
with each other so they're they they
they take dmt and then pass out on the
couch right and then we're in the same
place
talking with each other that's amazing
yeah something maybe maybe i'm sorry no
it's all good maybe it's they fill in
the gaps afterwards like they're you've
brain damaged yourself right and then
you're like
right and then maybe you go oh man it
was like there's a giraffe there and
then i remember i said you should do a
backflip and then go you did say to do a
backflip we were there together and it's
like or maybe you just did drugs right
something i encountered a lot in the
in in georgia in this town was a
coincidence all the time every time i
turn around there was another
coincidence one small one would be like
you know having a general and or
a colonel in the union whose name was
jefferson davis but another one would be
like uh in this town in washington uh
this writer who i found her book she
wrote like all like the straight
reporting from like the early 1900s
everything was about like the stump has
been removed or this person has died and
whatnot
but one was uh this woman was sick and
it was like 1890 and she traveled 40
miles north
and uh that night she woke from in a
fever and had a dream and told her
husband uh that town has burnt down and
she told him the direct path of the fire
and then the next day this guy came up
on the train and said uh the the town
burned down and then the father went the
husband went down and it was like the
same path and like okay that's that's
weird maybe but like the fact that that
lady had written so much straight
reporting like i'm like that's crazy i
should add that there are so many
stories like that throughout human
history i wonder a lot of it can be
explained away but every so often you're
like come on i wonder if it's like
pattern recognition like you see the
vibe subconsciously you see the the wind
blowing through the trees and then that
you know deep in your soul that that
means that something is going to happen
tomorrow like a guy's going to say hello
to you around 11 o'clock if it's that or
if it's more like we're tapped into some
external vibration that we are but we're
detached from it right now i think
because we're not paying attention
enough and i think i was experiencing so
many coincidences in in this town
because i was hyper aware of the town
while i'm there and doing a ton of
research so
every time every day there was some new
weird coincidence whether it was
personal or in my research or whatever
but i think that's because i was like so
uh observing of this one thing and i
think it happens on hopefully on a
broader scale for people i really like
the magnetic universe theory you guys
studied the electric universe theory at
all thunderbolts project is doing a lot
of good work on it and um it basically
indicates like gravity as we know it is
actually a form of magnetism maybe it's
like um i don't know what they call it
when a wheel starts to spin so fast that
it looks like it's spinning backwards
right there's a resonant frequency so
you've got like this resonating
frequency of magnetism that looks like
gravity but it works like it the closer
you get to earth the faster you get
stuck to it just like a magnet the
closer magnet gets to a magnet the
faster it gets stuck to it and so i
wonder if we're inside of like just this
magnetic field vibrating and so it's all
obviously inside the black hole that
cern created in 2008 right yeah we're
still in there yeah sorry the earth was
destroyed we all got sucked in i'm just
imagining it's uh you said 2008 you said
or 2016. i thought it was 2008 when it
started oh they started it yeah but in
2016 they fired it up and also trump won
i mean earlier but yeah they only fire
every few years because it's so so is
the is the original timeline still there
somewhere
well
i'm just imagining they're like you know
they're flicking all the switches and
they're like getting ready to fire it up
and then all of a sudden they're like
are we ready all right ten nine and then
all sudden like a gasket blows and like
where where they're like what's going on
the power levels are going through the
roof what do we do shut it down i can't
it's locked in
[Music]
and then everyone inserts like no and
then like a wave just ripples across the
universe and then all of a sudden like
donald trump is about to give his
concession speech and then the wave just
hits everyone and then also he goes i'm
the president and everyone's like yeah
and they're clapping and cheering that's
how it happened it feels that way
yep i think we're trapped in it
meanwhile hillary clinton was in like a
protective case like sphere with her
with her uh you know security team and
they're like what just happened and then
they look at the tv and like the
timeline changed and she's like no
no and you know what happened the
russians
planted a device in cern overloading the
power supply to manipulate the timeline
that's that'd be a that'd be a fun movie
wouldn't yeah i like this the gas prices
are high because of cern you're saying
right right such weird that's always say
when um whenever the simulation's going
crazy i'll i'll tweet this sometimes
they're like like they got they got
certain cranked up again don't they boys
simulations run a little hot right now
and you just you just turned it down
just a little bit not the only super
collider in the world they've been doing
this for a while like i think they
wanted to do cern here in the beginning
well we we have um we have fermilab yeah
yeah smaller
my favorite bit is that we're in a
simulation but it's not like some grand
intelligent being it's just like some
dude in college who's playing a video
game he's like playing you know
simulation earth 27
and then his like he like puts his drink
down to go to the bathroom and sets the
controller down and then he comes back
his little brother's playing and he goes
billy what are you doing dude give me
the control oh now donald trump's
president come on i gotta fix this i
think for sure we cracked some sort of
code in the simulation when we harnessed
electricity because we're able to listen
to the past now we have like a portal
like this video people are watching it
now
from where we did this before you're
listening to it now but you're listening
to it from whenever you come back and
watch those those like early early
restoration videos that people have done
from like the 18 years
jackson's documentary about world war
one right now
oh man it's such one of the best war
documents but it's it's the ones that
get me though is
it it'll just be someone and you can
tell that it's the first camera first
certainly first video camera that
anyone's ever seen because people are
walking past it in the street and it's
like this is what 1890s paris looked
like yeah and people were walking past
the camera
going like what the heck is that thing
why is it here
why are you filming us
and the people have gotten really and um
there's one youtuber that does it and
it's he'll put he'll because they were
they were silent right but he's got he
goes in and puts in like period-specific
sound effects
and it's is one of the most trippy
things that you'll ever see because
you're looking and you know that
everyone in this video is dead right
that's the one thing i always think but
it literally to your point in it's it's
we are looking into a mirror and an
image into the past through electricity
yeah it's a portal portal i i want i've
noticed with internet video i started an
o6 and i started doing the manifestation
thing where i would tell people this
something is real and then if people
would believe it it would start to seem
more real and things started to like
coalesce like
like i would just say
it's gonna something's gonna happen
there's pun thousands of videos up of me
doing this stuff or a thousand or
something and it was like how am i so
tapped into reality now like before i
felt so helpless like i was an observer
on reality and then i started doing
internet video and i felt like i was
controlling and creating reality no but
but tied this back to what we were
talking about earlier right you know
governments have had this power for a
long time right the gulf of tonkin
incident right you know you go back to
the 1960s and you straight up people
were told right we were attacked america
was attacked and we need to go to war
because this happened and you had people
that fought um
syria not just fought in the war but
also fought serious political battles
based on the and for them they believed
that truth so inherently um you could
say the same thing for the main the uss
maine in the spanish-american war
which was even a little bit less
government intervention more they
consider it yellow journalism
of the time and and
hurst and gets into all that stuff and
multiple what how many wars have been
started because of something like this
and so the question is was this a power
right was this a persuasion power that
was used by governments and in some
cases by media because they've basically
understood that if you just tell that
big enough right you you do for all
intents and purposes make it real dude
it's so crazy to think that all of
history that we know of is just told to
us if the news are fake imagine history
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you